that's the theorem think back to what we
were looking at before we
we drew a triangle that was
three and then four and to our surprise
we found that there was a five up here
have a look at this theorem let's let's
crunch the numbers
okay here's a and b
a and b right so you do a squared plus b
squared that would be 3 squared plus 4
squared
three squared is nine four squared is
sixteen which is
twenty-five which of course is five
squared
okay i can go again i can go again what
was the next triangle we drew
i believe it was a 5 and then a 12
and then uh 13 it's true
25 plus 144 is 169
okay you can go again the la the largest
triangle we drew
was 8 15 17
64 plus 225 is 289
it works for every triangle
even the really funky ones
i'm going to leave that up there as a
question mark for a second i said i
promised i would leave this all up on
the board i assume most people haven't
finished writing everything down so i'll
give you a couple of minutes to catch up
give it a couple of minutes because if
you have written everything
then i wonder if you can work out what
that question mark is actually without
measuring it
we had a look at this here are some
examples of it now here
we were like 4.1 1.2
who knows okay well we can actually work
it out we can work it out using
pythagoras theorem
excuse me so here's what we're going to
do
i'm going to call this h anyone want to
suggest y h
it's not just because i don't like
hypotenuse thank you very much it's not
just because i don't like abcd and so on
until g ooh h i finally like it h for
hypotenuse
okay now that i've given it a name
i can work with pythagoras's theorem
here okay
so go back to where you drew this
triangle right at the top if you've got
some space here
we're going to write this sentence
pythagoras theorem
for this triangle okay it should be
three squared
plus three squared they're the shorter
sides
should be equal to h squared very good
now where does that come from where it
comes from is pythagoras theorem that's
the reason why this is true
so i'm actually going to write over here
i've run out of space
so i'm just going to squeeze it in
pytharius's
theorem okay that's the reason and you
should write it as well
okay this doesn't just come out of thin
air just like this doesn't come out of
thin air it comes from reasons
well this comes from a region as well
okay so i'm going to put there
pythagoras
now i can work out the answer right we
know what three squared is it's a small
number
it's nine so i've got nine plus
nine nine plus nine of course is
eighteen so now i have h squared
equals 18. okay
so now if i want to know what h itself
is equal to not h
squared right that's why we spent all
this time i rubbed it off
looking at certain square roots h will
be
the square root of eighteen now i know
it's between
four and five because the square
of sixteen square root of sixteen is
four the square root of twenty-five is
twenty-five right five five so tell get
your calculator out what's it actually
good
um
okay excellent
so now you can see why some people
measured 4.2
some people measured 4.3 if we measured
4.1
maybe something went wrong that's okay
right we're just doing
the ruler okay so accuracy is not a
bigger deal but now we know
now we know exactly we didn't even need
to draw this triangle
the answer's there